so good evening or good afternoon for
those of you who don't know me I'm
Nicholas Negroponte a I'm one of the
cofounders of the Media Lab and I'm not
gonna really be the emcee but you're
gonna see me come and go and if people
take too long I might be pushed out to
grab them off the stage I was not only a
colleague of Muriel I think it's fair to
say she was my best friend I've known
her since the early 1960s and she had an
enormous influence on me and even though
she was roughly 20 years older than I we
did things as almost like brother and
sister we traveled together we worked
together I was in the architecture
department at one end of the building on
Massachusetts Avenue and she was on the
other end and we really spent so much
time together I would say on average
dinner twice a week obviously that's
average and partly that was because her
house and MIT if you drew a straight
line I was in the middle of it so she
would pick me up with this Chevrolet
Impala that was infested with dog hairs
I would get into garbage bags cuz I wore
a suit and a tie in those days and I
would get into the car with my garbage
bags we come to she dropped me off at
building seven and she'd go to the MIT
press and then when the media lab got
created on the visible language workshop
that you'll hear a lot about became very
much part of the initial groups that
that sort of formed the Media Lab and
Muriel worked here as one of our most
colorful and important faculty members
now there are two murals there's a
Muriel that we know from her work and
they're quite a few people in the room
who didn't know her as a person a
because you may be too young or you just
didn't have the the chance to know
Muriel and the Muriel that we see in her
work is
crisp it's incisive it's almost
Cartesian it's maybe even Helvetica if
you could use the word generally to
describe something rather Swiss and
precise and the Muriel the second Muriel
the persona I guess the first word be
much more colorful much less decisive
for those of you who remember going out
for dinner with Muriel and how she
ordered food at a restaurant
it drove waiters crazy she'd say well no
I know well can you make this without Oh
actually I prefer that if it doesn't the
succotash without the corn and Sona and
it was it was a much it wasn't crisp and
so that the two the two murals created
an influence that just never left this
laboratory and I'm sure many people who
didn't know the persona will by the end
of today because a lot of the speakers
knew Muriel very well a lot of the
participants also did so coffee break
everybody will have Muriel Cooper
stories and I'm not gonna bore you with
with too many of these but in the early
days of the Media Lab we had a lot of
funding from the military and there was
a general who was in charge of what I
think was then called the Seventh Army
which was all the Army in Europe and uh
who came to the Media Lab and met Muriel
and when he meets Muriel he says how
much do you know about theaters and she
said I know a lot I studied I was
studied to be an actress nice and that's
not that kind of theater and he then
sort of he says to these guys don't come
alone there's privates of people and he
says where's the men's room and a
private says a hand grenades throw down
the corridor sir
Muriel used that expression
for the next ten years she would tell
people oh you need the men's room it's a
hand grenades reppin to have the card so
that's the kind of person Uriel was when
Jerry Wiesner and I were raising money
this was before this bill the either
building was built he brought Avery
Fisher around and he says let's go
introduce Avery Fisher to Muriel and he
introduces Muriel says mural this is
Avery Fisher and Muriel says oh are you
the fat cat and Jerry wanted to die he
never forgave her he quoted the story
over and over again but he always did it
with a lot of laughs so I think today
you'll hear if you don't hear explicit
stories you're gonna hear about a person
who really made the Media Lab different
we pride ourselves and being different
but boy Muriel was very very different
so in keeping with that when we did this
Evander when we were starting to think
of this event it's almost the case that
the people who aren't here are dead that
was the only excuse almost everybody
else came and there really was almost a
hundred percent showing in terms of the
who was invited and and who actually got
here and then when we asked people to
help with the graphics and people to
help do the event we go to our usual
port of call the gold standard of
graphics we went to pentagram now we go
to pentagram for everything so going to
pentagram wasn't that special but
pentagram thanks to Aaron thanks to
Aaron Fay Michael Beirut and I don't
know if I know have I met Daisy Lee are
you here she does all the work
well she's not even here but you guys
you know you hit it out of the box and I
know exactly why and we're gonna see
this again over the afternoon so I don't
have to introduce the next speaker
Muriel well in the video that I believe
will roll in a second
thank you MIT press for quite a while
she's been with the Media Lab for quite
a while she's always been two or three
steps ahead of me with everything she
did and it's an honor and a pleasure
that Muriel join us today thank you I
have a confession and I hope that
everybody in the audience will forgive
me in those early days when we were both
very young and terrified
I made the mistake I remember how I did
it I remember when I did it and I think
I remember where I did it but I'm damned
if I know why I did it
I introduced Nicky to Ricky can you tell
I know you're filming this or doing
something but turn the lights down so I
can see the audience please please just
turn them down somebody has a switch for
the lights and I know you don't want to
do it but it'll be fine just turn them
down please so I can see the audience
those lights that are in my face that's
just better oh yes I have to do that
every time you give a speech you can't
see the audience and if you can't see
your face how can you give a job well by
opening lines were not Nikita Ricky but
I was going to say that Nicholas I was
introduced to Nicholas by by Muriel she
changed my life yeah but this live is
have moments lives are not continuum so
you might look back and think there
continued to know there just moments and
you forget a lot of the [ __ ] between the
moments but the moments they really
change you and
it's not that you should forget that
this stuff between it but it really is
just stuff a lot of stuff like George
Carlin used to talk about stuff anyway
she introduced me to Nicolas in the when
he had the architecture machine and that
was a change in my life and her wanting
to introduce me to somebody else who she
felt was very important was a change in
my life recently people have been
telling me that I'm abrasively charming
and and there's a certain truth in both
those things that I am abrasive and I am
charming I know you're not supposed to
say either about yourself but it's
perfectly clear what I'm saying and if
you're clear that beats every other
thing just being clear is enough and so
I could never get any I wouldn't have
gotten them the media the MIT press er
or anybody else to publish any of my
little books and I have been doing books
for a while I just have an idea and I do
a little book and I don't have a
publisher right I spit it out but she
she indulged me and got them to do
exceptions about a whole bunch of little
booklets that I did over the years and
they really they really she really
changed my life I did something for her
but I didn't know I was doing it and she
didn't know I was doing it but in the
last year of her life I finally got to
her and she's everything that that that
Nicolas said the dogs the car her taking
off her shoes walking around in her
socks and they just but she didn't know
she was doing it there was just what she
was what she you know if I I used to
dress funny when I went to pen
but I knew purposely I was trying to get
attention she wasn't trying to get
attention she was just being herself
it's just about as genuine as she could
be I mean that was just her I was always
more phony that she was Moses came in so
her stuff here number of times by the
way this is I said it to the Juan
Enriquez as I came in we had a quick
conversation and for some reason I had
never said that before but I realized
that it's something I should repeat this
is you know the greatest real school in
the world there's some woowoo schools
schools that are probably nice that
little kids count beads and they do
things and they think they learned to be
nice people and and all those things
there's a lot of little woo schools at
different things in experimental schools
but this school is extraordinary we what
Nicholas has done the others following
Nicholas paralleling that was the effect
he said well this is I walked around I
was early because I had nothing to do
and I walked around the school and my
goodness it really is Disneyland for
grownups it's it's it's a dream it's
it's the waking dream and so this is a
great place that we're all sitting in
here and great places attract great
people and Muriel was a great person she
was just simply a great person and I
finally convinced her at the I started a
conference I ran for a while called Ted
and I finally convinced her to come to
one of the fifth TED Conference and she
came with David small who's in the
audience here and they came and I had
her scheduled I think for this second
day for I don't remember when you were
scheduled David but I think it was the
second they might have been the first
and she came with David and they had
nothing they had nothing to show they
hadn't worked on it she just came in and
I was just depressed about that
and so I changed the bike I could do
what I want to change the program and I
think they were on the fourth day and
then they stayed up for three days and
they developed they developed their
presentation it was it was a Charette
beyond charettes it was amazing I told
David if I say something that least
makes the story understandable not to
stand up if I say something that really
disturbs him and is not factual so it
that he should stand up and stop me I'm
just telling you my memory of it right
and then they did this amazing
presentation and it was live they had
computers all over this is a long time
ago this is just a long time I spent
when nothing worked
I mean literally nothing working but you
knew that anybody who was doing a
presentation with a computer wasn't
gonna work they'd have to boot it up
again it was just the way it was it was
acceptable and it was astonishing it was
just astonishing and it was my dream it
was a dream and I always stayed on stage
I think I left the stage to watch it
that time I always used to stay on say
so I could stand behind people to have
him stop talking and I left the stage
and watched it and I just I was
transplant I didn't think you could do
that and I said it was like flying
through information throwing flying
through understanding it was something
new we've gotten so used to it we see it
no god damn ads now we're always flying
through letters and flying through
things that that was Muriel and her
students there was something that was
broke through it was a breakthrough in
thinking about computer graphics and
content not computer graphics and just
graphics and pretty and flexing muscles
it was with contact high content and
and it was three-dimensional maps of
time there was all kind of aerial maps
it was with Cirque de Soleil with people
with printouts on them it was special it
was really special and I recorded I
didn't record it I can't even type but I
had people record record things and that
little video is as far as I know the
only evidence that she and David and her
students and her head in her time and
her dog in her car and there you know
and everything put that together and
it's become a icon icon of a moment in
history when some things came together
it's like the photograph that Watson and
Crick used to build their ticker to a
model is a moment in time that puts
something together that we can stamp
when people started thinking that way
and it allowed people to think
differently because the tool allows you
to think of things you couldn't think of
except for the first person who does
that Michelangelo stands in front of a
huge piece of stone and he wouldn't be
able to do anything about it until
somebody had invented prior to that a
hammer and a chisel and that'll says
well I could let Moses out because he
has a hammer and chisel but he couldn't
even think of doing that it was he
couldn't scrape him out with his
fingernails so her tools were these
abilities to think of things that have
changed our lives
somebody came up to me before this and I
forget the conversation I forget who it
was but what came up was something I was
thinking about a few weeks ago of how my
life changed at a certain time when I
was at 10 I'm 82 so you can know how
many years ago there was
and I was doing the student magazine
there and it was there wasn't such a
thing as offset printing except by an
experimental printer in downtown
Philadelphia Jean Feldman at Falcon
Press but be sort of that everything was
done with you know the way you said type
and do it so you couldn't think of
actually doing something else you
couldn't think of all the things that
pentagram does that everybody they
wouldn't come into your head because you
didn't have a they couldn't be
actualized so that they aren't the
creation but the tool allows you to
think of things and her she skipped the
idea that without the tool she broke
through and asked asked of our new
inventions do something that she was her
waking dream and we've benefited from
that
well I won't beat that dead horse
there's a little light there and I'm
gonna I don't know how much time I spoke
I know I have 15 minutes and I have this
takes six minutes and I realize I can't
write better than I wrote then it's just
six minutes and this was the I did a
book called information architects and I
dedicated it to mural many many many
years ago and this is what I read I put
that in the book and this is what I read
at her at the the services for her after
she died and I was with her the day
before she died a day and a half before
she died she was in a nagi conference
over in Cambridge and we're hanging with
Bobbie Greenberg she and I and a few
others and she had to get back home
Nicholas's memory is slightly different
than mine I don't know what's right but
doesn't make any difference what's right
she came home and Nicholas asked her to
introduce somebody and we know that she
passed away suddenly at that at that
moment but she showed twice the thing
that you've all seen I think where it's
around this you're there show it today I
don't know what the program is today but
it was shown we saw it live at Ed who
was shown one other time afterwards and
then the last time was at the Ossie
conference in Cambridge and
that was remarkable first day so I'm
gonna come down here and read that I do
have six minutes left whoever's keeping
time do I still have six minutes say yes
please
okay I'm coming here because I saw that
there was more light here
somebody turned down those lights okay
I'm not good at reading I'm sorry I am
better at talking but this is good to
read
I believe that Muriel has wings we met I
was 29 and she was 38 we last left and
planned together on the day before she
was to die I was 59 and she was 68
I knew her for 30 years on my first
meeting I felt those wings as they
wrapped a mammy wrap around me like a
mother hand I was sharp tongue arrogant
coming to MIT MIT press trying to get my
ideas published and she walked me
through the door after door that I
couldn't myself navigate or open I next
saw the wings as they created a wind and
showed me the wind of change she
introduced me to Nicolas and the notion
of dreams of finding your way through
information a different kind of
navigation the next winds wings I saw I
saw her where were the wings of a piece
tough as she read I'd and passionate
struggled to get McLuhan's book is
anyone taking any notice published that
poignant book about the Vietnam War and
death
she wore wings on her many kardia
graphic exercises flying on airplane
wings flying in space over maps over
information watching as the aerial
perspective changed with clouds
refocusing her vision of a man created
reality the wings of triumph and the
aura of discovery were all around Muriel
at the Ted 5 conference she worked with
David small for three days to assemble
together the premiere of a presentations
which she hesitantly at first then with
noticeable joy
showed to the extraordinary audience of
that conference it changed forever the
visual paradigm of information for all
who saw the presentation as I came on
stage holding back the tears of joy that
come when you when you've seen some
something absolutely magnificent I said
Muriel I believe we've all had dreams of
fly and here you allowed us to make
those dreams a reality
as we're flying through information it
was a real-time display of heavenly
navigation later here at the Media Lab
she once again went through the
presentation with Bill Mitchell and
myself as bookends and the three of us
talking - Nicholas's class and then
three months later having retitled the
presentation flying through information
she showed the videotape to the Alliance
graphic international og at Cambridge
England Henry Steiner who was from Hong
Kong and then president neva G had seen
it at Ted
Bob Greenberg and I spoke with her of
what was going to happen next and what
the dreams of flying through information
released in each of us for me it was the
ability to control one's personal
understanding that was the day before
she died I do believe mural has wings
they are wings that will encourage her
students to be more of themselves that
will allow the people seeing her apathy
onic and empowering information
structure to dream of understanding she
was an architect of information she now
has the wings that few get that in death
she will be in the waking dreams of
those who are touched by the wind from
her feathers of change in discovery
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
can you see me hello hello there are two
very important things that the visible
language workshop is is looking at one
is the way in which graphics which we
define in the broadest sense can be used
to filter define qualify and edit that
information and secondly what the
interface or the relation that the
surface are the access of the person to
the machine can be like to promote the
most creative and the most generative
means of communication and again if you
look at the computer as an environment
in which you which you do multiple tasks
and which is ubiquitous in your life
then it's even more important that this
personalization and configurability take
place because today I may want to work
on music and then go to my cookbook and
then read my newspaper or design my
newspapers
[Music]
so go away where's my note on the back
of this now I've lost my [ __ ] nose
huh so oh Jesus here it is on the floor
okay don't stop here we go I'm ready
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Michael Beirut of pentagram we've
assembled a panel to talk about Muriel
as a designer like some of the other
unlucky people here I don't think I've
ever met Muriel I sent her a letter in
the late 70s that Rob Weisenberger found
and sent me a copy of that seems to
indicate that I may have met her I can't
really I don't remember writing the
letter and I don't remember what
provoked me to write this letter but I
corresponded with her in some way and so
at least we have that remote connection
but her influence as as Nicholas said is
so broad and so deep that almost anyone
practicing graphic design today would
say that they have somehow met Nerio
Cooper we've got three people who can
talk about this in more depth
Aran vinegar who's professor at the
University of Oslo and the author of
several books including I'm a monument
which is about Muriel and her work on
learning from Las Vegas the epical
volume by Denise Scott Brown and Robert
venturi Ben Frey the creator of the
programming environment called you
called um processing I'm sorry
you need a better catch here name than
them he's a winner of the National
Design Award from the cooper-hewitt
Museum from for interaction design as is
at least one other speaker here this
evening and then finally Ellen Lupton
who is the senior curator for
contemporary design at the National
Design Museum and so she's the person
who sort of hands out those awards and I
will point out this very evening is
evening of the National Design Awards in
New York City
Ellen is honor bound to be there but
instead here so that just shows where
the priorities are when Muriel Cooper
has something to say about them so I'd
like to invite Ellen to talk about I did
get to meet Muriel very profound and I
was in the audience when Ricky didn't
take his shoes off but she did and
showed that amazing video and I was
trying to think what would she have made
of this today all of you hear a giant
book about her work an honorary elevator
button her name typeset in 35,000 point
purple Helvetica I think she would have
liked it you know girls are supposed to
be embarrassed by all the attention but
I'll tell you a secret we like it it's
good it's good and what would she have
thought about the world of media today
this exploding
uncontrolled metastatic networked mass
of digital communication she said it all
she really knew what was happening and
it's been a great pleasure to kind of
think again about her work and to read
the wonderful essays about her voice and
her students in the book that Rob and
David put together
Muriel can't be here today but I want
her to be here and so I pulled together
some of her words because she needs to
speak and she was so articulate about
the questions that obsess people like me
and Michael what is a book what is an
author what is the role of graphic
designers in all of that what is the
nature of communication and what what is
it that we do damn it that adds value to
communication
I pulled out a couple of her most
stunning and important or famous books
but they're the books in which she had
the most role as an author and then her
decades at MIT in her role at MIT press
she was creating systems and ways that
books could kind of generate themselves
but she also really got her fingers and
hands in mind into certain books that
very much bear her stamped as a
co-author of information
she thought that books were like movies
she wanted to eliminate the gap between
the designer and the process of printing
and shaping information so she played
with offset as this kind of live medium
emotion medium she used the grid in her
amazing Bauhaus book as a way to to give
structure and architecture but also to
create constant change and surprise my
favorite part is the index I'm sure she
spent a lot of time on that index and I
think this is this is a this is actually
the manuscript for the Bauhaus book this
is what we do we take a pile of [ __ ]
like that right these thousands of pages
that is not a book it is not a book
until someone comes through and gives it
shape and makes it accessible to human
beings to find their way in and out and
she talked about that she talked about
graphic design as a kind of filtering of
this mess the stream of information the
junk that authors hand us and that we
make into something coherent and she saw
that the future would give readers and
writers better ways to find their way
through information to give it a better
shape and she was interested in
information that should go away she
didn't feel that everything should stay
on the planet forever and she thought
that designers had a role in making data
disappear I wish more people had paid
attention to that I think that's really
important and in this book which Aaron
will talk about more we can kind of see
the the battle for authorship between
two great women of design theory and
thinking Muriel Cooper and Denise Scott
Brown the real author and the graphic
design author Muriel I think was
frustrated by being told what to do by
the author and she created this
incredible book that provided a kind of
new interface for connecting image and
text for allowing us to absorb the image
as a kind of text and to kind of fit
those things together in an incredibly
eloquent way so if you come in close to
this book you'll see that that wide
letting made space for these little
figure numbers which are keyed to the
pictures and allowed the reader to go
back and forth between the text and the
image in an absolutely brilliant way
apparently Denise Scott Brown didn't
like that very much and there exists in
the papers of Muriel Cooper interchanges
between these two great women fighting
about the book and Denise thought it was
too interesting to Bauhaus too much noiz
of the graphic designer in there and
what she wanted was something more
conventional which is what she got later
right all that Muriel had the last word
on that talking about the author and you
can see here the kind of frustration of
graphic designers feeling boxed in and
told what to do and what she really
wanted is for us to all have tools to be
authors and designers and publishers and
boy did we get those tools okay
thank you thank you very much
I came to Mira Cooper's work directly
through her design work I'd never met
her in person I first encountered
actually when I started working on
learning from Las Vegas like many people
I first encountered the book on the
right which is the revised version the
boring version I guess that was designed
by Denise Scott Brown and then worked
myself back to the the original version
designed by Maria looper and I guess I
was kind of stunned by her approach to
design and vision which I initially you
know was directed towards the design
work that's kind of complicated
I think prefiguring her later interest
in the visible language workshop on
texture layering transparency a kind of
dynamism to the text interrelations
between text and image as Alan said you
can see the extreme letting the triple
spacing of the main text juxtaposed by
the very tight text in the margins and
so forth here's another example of the
layout of Mariel Cooper's design and I
did see the difference that Denise Scott
Brown really did not like the Swiss
treatment of her book and really wanted
a much more boring or she called it
deadpan approach to the book with very
regularized text and image the kind of
that had the the images grouped together
here here you can see the the use of the
grid this was drawn for me by sally
Steiner in showing you the grid that
Marilla Cooper used and then again this
image which was also supposed to kind of
replicate the movement through the city
and the lines of the tact
are kind of the roadways or the highways
and the numbering of the images are
meant to be like signs so your way of
reading is like moving through the city
and this kind of sense of movement is
also kind of demonstrated in these
layouts this is a layout for part one of
learning from Las Vegas so Muriel Cooper
could see the arrangements of text and
image and flow and so and so forth and
the filmic dimension is really important
here but I think I want to mention what
I learned from her what I think about
her work that's important and this is
the kind of triadic relationship between
communication movement and experience
and I think I have a little bit of a
different attitude to what communication
is perhaps than traditional designers
I'm not a designer and to me
communication is exposing us to the risk
of experience that means traversing
something pushing against limits
undergoing something and this kind of
attitude towards experience really is
about discovering a path it's not
formulating a method it is not deploying
kind of preconceived formats whether
those are grids or not it is really at
the exposure for us to experience
something new and to undergo it not to
have an experience but to and not to own
it or anything like that but to actually
undergo it and move along a path so a ho
dose a path method is can the word
method consists of the word ho dose
which is path and I don't think she ever
deployed anything you know preconceived
although of course she was deploying
Swiss kind of graphic design but the the
kind of material spills out over this
and I think what she brought to her
further work in visible language
workshop is that the book was undergoing
a really rapid change in 1972 things
were opening up and this was a site of
experiment the book was no longer an
archaic stillness but was being opened
up and kind of proliferating
by the work of people
like you know designers at the time and
theorist and so forth and Muriel Cooper
was at the forefront of that and that
kind of issue about movement and
information and complexity a book isn't
just to be read for information but
something like the size of the learning
from Las Vegas book the original version
you can't sit there and read it right
you need to place it on a table you need
to move it around explore it move
through the information and this kind of
attitude gets carried on and carried
forth in her later work with the visible
language workshop but that lot of that
was enabled by her exploration a book
design I think so that's what I was
impressed with with her work and my
encounter with her work thanks Aaron
so I don't typically read when doing a
doing a talk I've been ill lately and I
have a four month old at home and so I
have the memory of a mosquito and I want
to make sure that you know this sort of
give this subject it's it's due here so
at the risk of dating myself I think it
probably saw the work of Mariel and the
vlw first in a Wired magazine a couple
years later I was this senior at
Carnegie Mellon and recent vlw alums
saguru ishizaki brought Dave small and
John mighty to speak and this was the
first time that I saw how my interest in
graphic design and computer science
might actually be combined in a more
interesting way than just sort of you
know jamming them together as a student
I'd already worked professionally as a
graphic designer
and separately as a software developer
but it always kind of hated computer
graphics because I found them to
represent everything I despised about
the usual collision of art and
engineering a bunch of engineers trying
to replicate a Mondrian painting and
calling it art or 3d graphics with
spheres and cubes and incandescent RGB
colors so synthetic and alien that they
hardly seemed at home and computer
itself I love that Mariel remained a
designer first and it shows the
influence of their work as seen in her
students often when designers start
working with computation as a medium
there's a tendency to shut off their
design instincts because they're in this
foreign in sort of technical space to
make the transition you really need to
think keep your critical eye and treat
computation isn't just another medium
that is you know as imperfect as any
other and learn from it's working within
its constraints by also trying to
challenge yourself to overcome them
Merrill did this with her students with
the vo they'll be exploring things like
depth of field and blur and anti-alias
text many years before these would
become commonplace these came from an
approach grounded in fields like
photography and film and typography and
a desire to make this cold medium a
little bit more human humanistic in 2001
I'd been a student of John Midas for
three years and began working with Casey
Reis on what would become processing a
project that seeks to make it easier to
merge these disciplines of design and
code and it is a direct
of coding libraries the date to the vlw
plus the pedagogical side of what we did
at the AC G and finally the desire to
sketch with code so write writing short
programs that are easily iterated upon
the same way that you work in your
sketchbook the dvw name even lives on as
the font format used by processing which
stores information in exactly the same
way as the type used in that information
landscapes video we saw earlier millions
of users later we have a mission
statement for the processing project
which reads processing seeks to ruin the
careers of talented designers by attempt
tempting them away from their usual
tools and into the world of programming
and computation similarly the project is
designed to turn engineers and computer
scientists to less gainful employment as
artists and designers and I hope that
point would resonate with Muriel after
she took a class with Nicholas
Negroponte II she's quoted to have said
that the code on screen didn't make any
goddamn sense I've always felt that
these are precisely the people that I
want to bring into the field the
technically inclined will always find
their way regardless and but they'll
also make things that are more suited to
their technical interests and so a field
gets interesting however only and only
really truly evolves when it expands by
bringing in people with different
abilities and kinds of experiences and
as far as accessibility we've come a
long way since the vlw era where this
work was limited to research labs using
computers the size of a mini fridge by
the early 2000s you could buy a computer
for a few hundred dollars to do this
type of work which meant that the means
was in place we just provided the
platform or we just needed to provide
the platform which KC and I sought to do
with processing and now in the current
decade the means is ubiquitous and
processing continues with newer
initiatives like the p5.js project which
takes the same ideas and tries to
rethink them for you know sort of
contemporary web setting but more
importantly Lauren McCarthy has led the
project with a renewed focus on
inclusion and diversity meaning that
we're at a point where we have more room
to consider what this means socially and
how we can really extend the boundary of
those participating in the field the
evolution over the last couple decades
reminds me of a wonderful John Adams
quote paraphrase goes something like I
must study politics so that
some may have Liberty to study
mathematics and philosophy and my sons
will study geography and commerce and
agriculture to give their children the
right to study painting poetry music and
architecture we owe and on we owe an
enormous debt to Muriel and her students
providing the spaces for us and I'm
honored to be participating today thank
you
when Ellen and then Erin we're talking
about the tension that occurred between
Mura Cooper and Denise Scott Brown in
the design and production of learning
from Las Vegas one of the things that
that actually throws in a sharp relief
is that period when authors actually did
turn over to designers a pile of
manuscript that looked like that
photograph that Ellen showed and then
there was no choice but to have a
designer or some appointed professional
with arcane technical skills knowing the
names of typefaces knowing how to do
color separations and how to create
printed mechanical art work that could
communicate intention to a printer all
of those things were like you know what
uh avid Miller calls black arts in a way
that like civilians weren't didn't know
what were meant to know and certainly
authors were not meant to know or even
have an opinion about and so hence that
collision was so acute I think now it
you know and then as I'm as Ben just
said now we're in a period we're indeed
the means of production are in
everyone's hands and is it for the
better do you think then no question I
because I think the again it's it only
gets interesting as you bring the other
other kinds of people into it and so
it's kind of a you know you have people
who come in who are beginners but
they're experts somewhere else and so I
think it's really fascinating just to
take somebody who has that you know you
know something that they are expert at
but they're you know kind of bringing
that into into something new and that's
only
you know and so the the idea that the
where Muriel was bringing things like
from typography or from you know just
obvious things like you know so for
somebody who's ed who's worked with film
or photography that motion blur that's a
field are just you know the norm but for
somebody who's thinking from thinking
about things from a you know engineering
perspective well I'm trying to get the
shapes on screen you know and it's like
well so being able to kind of merge
those things together in a way that you
know it's just that's what you get at
that sort of that intersection
essentially and so I think the only way
you can do that is get as many people as
possible kind of using you know using
these kinds of tools and making messes
with them person you're on just a
clarification the this is not an answer
to that question but it's a bit of the
detail with the learning from las vegas
book it definitely wasn't dumping toilet
paper like these are people who had very
strong denise cop around Robert venturi
had very strong design ideas and thought
of themselves as designers no it was
very over developed or thought about in
in kind of very specific ways by the
time it arrived there that's innocent
and this takes us down a kind of
dangerously arcane graphic design Road
but loved it but um I think it's it's
easy if you're a graphic designer to
look at Mariel's design for that book as
being the design one and for to look at
the second the revised edition and the
one that I've in fact first saw and only
knew for many years is being sort of
like this undesigned piece of crap that
was like done put together by untutored
people but when I I you know the
intention behind it was very very
powerful in term and and Denise Scott
Brown's objections to murals is that we
really articulated and very you know I
can you sort of like describe what the
what Denise wanted out of that book I
think it's all a matter of timing so
actually it's odd because much is made
of the comp
between Muriel Cooper and Denise
Cockburn brown as the mirror Cooper said
it was a battle of wits you know and it
was a real kind of real conflict but you
know they had many things in common I
could go through them its interest in
movements they both were interested in
multiple graphic modes of representing
or accounting for sensory plenitude and
information landscapes I could go on and
on so why was the conflict and of course
a lot of it is is about timing and so
forth you know that second book you
could say is a treatise no it's an idea
of a text it wants to be a book you know
it wants to you know get across a set of
premises or polemics right and the first
all the more accessible and that's a
little paper bags keeping away from the
more pragmatic economic that's key I
think as a reader much as I love the big
book no but I don't want to actually
interact with it that is but the other
one was a kind of sense of the text or
what you know JJ Gibson would call a
sensory ecology that you don't get text
purified of it's you know sensory
plenitude and that's what you get in the
first book is a kind of a sense of the
text and the second book you get the
idea of a text or a treatise or a
polemic and those are kind of different
desires but you know originally said
Denise got problem they wanted a huge
book right at the beginning so you know
there got it the kind of thing yeah
belatedly and so these kinds of sense of
timings and and what you want to kind of
achieve polemically with your your body
of work shifts over time and what's
interesting of course is that that's the
the revised edition there's nothing to
do with that book except read it right
like looking at it it's no fun for me at
least you know there's some plates in it
they didn't look at but basically you
have no choice but if you want to engage
that book you have one way to do it
which is reading whereas I would
maintain the first edition a newly
released is you can really engage with
that book without actually reading it
and without actually perceiving and he
IV is impacting people will you know
have done and will do that so there's I
think I sort of get idea in the the
those two ways of looking at Texas
really pronounced and I think I'm it's
like so one of the things that I wonder
is was and then I'll put the C was she
was she was she reader did she was he
frustrated by by kind of the limited the
linear nature of a traditional book and
you know that informational landscape so
you know I mean I didn't get the
opportunity to work with but I mean do
you get a sense I think from the I think
what's interesting about the information
landscapes thing and that Richard
touched on it earlier as far as this
idea of how you actually move through a
space of information and I think it's
kind of that for people who you know
like working with information that
that's kind of these are the things that
like roll around them in their heads our
heads and keep us up at night and so I
think that was the kind of thing that's
kind of rolling around for her and that
this is like this is just you know the
way it's working in her head and then
when she makes a you know layout for a
book like the the Las Vegas book that's
kind of a moment frozen in time of that
picture that's been yeah you know it's
it's been in constant motion and then
all of a sudden here's this snapshot
that we're you know putting out in front
of people and so I think that sort of
thing you know it's really what what
comes through is how do you capture that
that motion and movement through the
through the information and you know I
think Nicholas and Ricky both kind of
referred to the revelatory quality of
that presentation of information
landscapes pretty early the first time
at Ted five and Isis and what strikes me
if you sort of see it today it's you
know there's not a single kind of you
know candy bar commercial on television
that doesn't use some sort of you know
kind of move that kind of first saw the
light of day and that thank you I mean
then so is
is have we reached some sort of you know
end point yeah Ellen is a curator very
end point where like you know we're now
we await the next thing the next kind of
transformation which maybe just emojis
or something I don't know well I think
you know now we're talking about you
know having text everywhere on our
glasses and we're gonna look around and
everything is gonna have text all over
it I think I'm waiting for that which
I'm sure yeah I think that there is
always this hunger for more and
different but I I do think that that
paradigm of the information landscape
from that conference you know what was
it 30 years ago was like a profound
moment because it wasn't just layers of
text that were parallel to the screen
but the fact of this moving like this
was mind-blowing because it was just
taking the perspective in a different
way and it was live text it wasn't
textures of text it was actual language
that could be edited I think also a lot
of what you see in the advertising and
sort of the versions of this that are
really pervasive are really kind of the
side effect of it you know you love when
type moves around and 3d on a screen and
like we're very drawn to it and we're
really drawn to language and things like
that but I think the fundamental kinds
of issues that Marilyn the vlw were
going after as far as how do you
actually move through a space of
information how do you actually interact
with it how do you you know understand
this we're still a long ways off from
actually you know fixing a lot more of
those core ideas and how do we you know
spend more more time kind of focused on
unpacking some of those issues that they
had just kind of started to scratch the
surface of I think sometimes when the
argument is of how she progressed from
book design the vlw that it was a limit
the book was to stay
you know all kinds of things that stayed
were kind of intervening on the kinds of
movement or that she wanted but I
actually think actually some of that
stillness remained in the design and I
think that's what's been lost this kind
of gap or temporal gap between the
acquisition of data and the plane of
discovery and those have been impressed
and here with her work you always had
that tough at the time to do that and
that temporal kind of extension and
duration has been rapidly closing and I
think that's that's an issue or what
gives her work that kind of interest or
death but I think yeah and I think um
when I look at her that Miroku purrs
later work when it's the screen-based
work in the digital work it always
really seems to have like it's not a
literary route to it at least it's sort
of thought it's me you understand that
that the informations meant to be
understood and interpreted and I think
if you sort of want to take it right up
at the present day
you know one of the reasons that we have
this crisis of you know you know what is
truth and what is fake news is that
information comes to people from all
sorts of different angles links to
things you know always looks good yeah
yeah and yeah and things were linked off
of things and they all look legitimate
they all they're all sort of coming out
of the same pipe and people make up
their own minds about what's true or not
and I think that that sort of is you
know that the authorial of the the you
know the authority that that authors
bring the things no mistake those words
I think at the same room you know I
which the difference between to treat us
and a pile of manuscript is sort of I
think a little bit what you know that
that gap is defines the the confusion
that pervades the world today common
yeah please now go ahead yeah yeah yeah
so Ricky points out if you didn't hear
it that it was really an attempt to
create a conversation on the page a
conversation with the text and sort of
the idea wellness of Talmudic Talmudic
commentary on a set text and there's you
know I would guess there's some officers
that actually don't like that they don't
want to have a conversation they just
like to have leave my wallet let me just
say my piece and read all the way
through and that wasn't me riyals point
of view or me realest point of view I
think was to enable people to access
tests in a lot of different ways and to
interact with it right actively so um so
um is there is there one big lesson that
we can learn from Uriel
today that would solve our problems as a
one I think she really what was really
driving so much of her work was the
desire to break down the mediation
between authorship and getting it out
there and the the idea that you could
have direct access to both the content
and its delivery I think that was just a
driving thing that she wanted to get rid
of that person you have to call up and
ask you know oh I have a typo well you
figured right people don't want to have
to do that they don't want to have to
call Michael Beirut and say fix my typos
they just want to be able to fix it and
I think that desire to get rid of that
mediation was really profound for her
and it was really important to me as an
author who also uses InDesign yeah I
want to fix my own typos Thank You
Muriel
I so most of my work is about you know
sort of understanding and working with
information and basically this this idea
of you know there's this massive
information out there and that design is
essentially the lens through which you
know the only lens through which we're
actually going to get the understanding
out of it and as far as I'm concerned
you know Marilyn really represents sort
of a patron saint of that that type of
thinking and that that way of how you
know how an individual actually
interacts with information as mediated
by you know by code and by that by the
computer is a as a digital tool so yeah
for me I think it's that communication
is not just conveying information but it
as I said exposing us to the risk of
experience and that it's it's as you
pointed out a conversation an encounter
and those kinds of things are precious
and need to be fostered and that allege
abilities and in communicability x' are
not external errors but they're
generated internally and those are
productive of some of our most
interesting encounters so when those
texts are shifting there are certain
points where palimpsest happens where it
erases information and just doesn't
reveal it and those are important points
and those I think those opacities blind
spots allege abilities are being kind of
wiped out and we need to find new ways
of preserving those kinds of things
difficulties well I'd like to thank our
panel Erin vinegar Ben Frey Ellen Lupton
please join me thank you very much
[Music]
this is a unscheduled introduction
because I'm not supposed to be doing it
but I thought you would like to know
something which John might not tell you
when we opened up the Media Lab in 1985
one of the less colorful groups was an
advanced television program which was a
very engineering approach to
high-definition and stuff like that
and there was this young graduate
student from Electrical Engineering
named John my ADA who was awfully
unhappy with his six-foot-two germanic
heel clicking advisor and he says oh I'm
so unhappy and I will really want to be
an artist and for one reason he drops
out he goes to Japan I think his parents
may have blamed me or other people but
they weren't happy and John goes Japan
end of story nine years later
Uriel dies 1994 May 28 and after
recovering which can't really do very
easily we set up a search an
international search for who could
replace Muriel Cooper well the answer is
nobody can replace Muriel Cooper but who
could we get that would be somewhat in
the same domain and this was not a fixed
wired search this was a real honest
global search and book John my ADA
appears from Japan and applies comes
here gives the talk and won that search
hands down and came back as a faculty
member which I'm sure his parents also
loved us for it now that you were back
John
thank you wow that was a nice
introduction I am a dropout
this true also faculty drop out now too
so I have a few presentation slides
because I started to be visual
I arrived roughly three hours ago and
began in the lobby to make a
presentation and I was trying to
understand like what I could say to all
of you because I know you'd all be here
so first of all who knew Muriel raised
her hand okay
so those who didn't up Muriel what did
her work change you and he's in any tiny
way
come on those he didn't know yeah I
didn't know but you just can't hey can I
hit you
grace Colby over there just threw a
button at me I changed her life as a
student and I see so many students here
of Muriel you'll get to see Dave small
later who where's Dave Dave's can we
talk later like Dave was that sort of
magical link between what Muriel's group
did and what my group did and I feel
very lucky okay let's bring up the
information okay heavy fancy pentagram
video Oh video problem
oh no problem okay so first of all I
want to note something that Ben Frey
didn't mention horse pen then over there
thank you press play
yeah Ben where are you Ben Ben coming
you're back there
so I arrived here at the Media Lab and I
had to like find students that's
something you have to do and him become
adult professor and ID no experience
doing that so what I began to do was I
was surfing all kind of websites looking
for people kind of like you know an
x-men or something trying to find the
mutants that can do the visual and can
do the code and I located this one
person named Ben fry who was at this
nominal company called Netscape they
were trying to make this thing no one
was gonna it was never gonna take off
whatever
and but somehow I convinced Ben to leave
that early stage startup sorry Ben to
come to the Media Lab and also like a
year later so gentleman appeared a name
k-series who told me that he really
wanted to come here he was a graphic
designer
but didn't know how to code and so I
said later than half line of code and he
said what I have to learn if let's C++
you have to know opengl mmm-hmm and
wrote it down in his notebook I gotta
tell you I tell like all kind of people
that same thing and they mm-hm and never
come back but a year later KC shows up
with his laptop and he says hi
I said you came back and says yeah after
I met you I quit my job and he was at a
dot-com thing a really good one and he
quit his job and began focusing on
computation and it's blew me away so I
just want to say that this place is very
special and this place really happened
because of a few people in this room but
most only be Nikolas over here who had
this vision that like a George Clooney
style Ocean's eleven or something that
this mix of people could create
something and I think that that
catalyzing force is so powerful because
yesterday I was at sponsored a you know
sponsored a it's like special private
viewing of things and so I was blown
away first of all I was seeing Neri
Oxman stuff and it was like amazing I
was sitting over there Oh merry now I
should see what you're like blowing my
mind like whoa you can do that now
and I also saw Gloriana special cameo
and Jojo Paradiso was showing his like
weird stuff which is always good it's
like you know a lot of bass and
mysterious and sensors and everywhere
and I saw also I'm turning my left and
there's like Hughes legs I'm like okay
cool right
and then I saw crush man Chris is the
person who invented the car navigation
system right if you imagine like the
Media Lab saw all these things had these
ideas they were outlandish at the time
why would you ever need your car to tell
you where to go right and of course my
dear friend Hiroshi Ishii I got to see
his lab Hiroshi makes everything like
vibrate and shake you know whatever and
so I had a great time I felt very Media
Lab II however stuff you can see here
but I came here today from Uriel I saw
also saw this special like you know
branded floor I was a little bit early
and I don't have a place here anymore so
I hung out in the lobby just sitting
there in the reasoner sort of like
special place who knew Jerry Wiesner who
knew this person so an amazing figure of
MIT stood for world peace like really
important stuff right so I saw that so I
just hung out there and worked and as I
worked there it's great because when
you're in this in this little place
suddenly you see all the details all
right because I've been to here like
four or five times but by sitting there
I also look at a video conference and
like wait there's a picture and I saw
this picture and this is like a really
good picture this is like a good picture
right and when I saw this picture it
reminded me of what to me MIT meant
because I really had never heard of
design when I came to MIT I was a
classical engineering student my parents
didn't have much money or education so
just coming here was the whole goal by
the time I got here I wasn't sure what
to do but I remembered looking at the
Media Lab and thinking well that's a
really weird place that seems very
unconventional
you know like it's a it's just a big
format it's got enemies everywhere I
don't understand it
let's make a cheaper and simpler right
and it's like I don't know what that was
and and I was talking to the person at
the front there was a person from member
relations and Sharon what'd you find out
because she's like knows everything in
the Media Lab you can ask her anything
and the front desk
that's a who's mural Cooper and she
wasn't sure so we cut the camera then
and then we did cut to famous person
yeah how does someone have a wonderful
legacy what's the secret what's your
name applause for Sharon
right you just kind of nailed it and
that's not about these things these four
words and I thought about passion and to
Nicholas this point you know I did have
this very special professor here at the
Media Lab who made my life a little bit
difficult in retrospect I'm very
grateful of course everything is better
in hindsight but I decided to leave but
I didn't know what to do and Muriel told
me to go to art school and it was the
best advice to give to me she said that
I wouldn't learn what I was wanting to
learn at a technical school because I
had done all the technical education the
problem engineering education is you
learn how to build anything but you
don't know what to build or why to build
it and so book an art school really
changed my life really so I thank Muriel
now this word enthusiasm is interesting
because something about enthusiasm is
something you might have as a rising
person someone who's gonna figure stuff
out and enthusiastic people tend to need
aspirational people right like how many
people had a hero
come on you had a hero and heroes and so
that hero was someone who was
aspirational and someone my friend told
me recently and Jesse and your friend an
artist told me how aspiration and
inspiration are two different things
aspiration is what you're trying to see
and you understand inspirations what's
awakens inside you and is the fire that
someone else gave you through having an
aspirational being so well I remember
like leaving here not sure what to do in
Japan I rebuilt my career as a designer
I came back to the computer and figured
out that this skill I had to make code
to Ben's point I knew what to make
suddenly it was so much easier and I
began publishing things in Japan and I
made this little book called the
reactive square which is ten squares
that respond to sound delivered in a
floppy disk I know very ancient but I
remember like ah this kind of feels so
right you know and I remember emailing
Muriel and saying hey I think I've
figured it out and she wrote back to me
and said show me and then a month later
she passed away so I remember when I
when I heard there was this call for
someone to somehow come here I saw it I
could never do that that's that's
impossible but I'd love to show my
respect and what happened is the day
before I came to the Media Lab to give a
faculty talk I was visiting this Idol
that I had Paul Rand again I didn't know
about design when I came to MIT once I
saw the media labs world I said I want
little more but it will have learned
more about design and I found a book by
Paul Rand by accident and the mi t--'s
rotes visual library I don't know if
it's still here but I was like whoa what
is this book this book is so fascinating
ah design really interesting I think I
want to do this many ways years later in
Japan the Paul Rand of Japan eco Tanaka
befriended me and said hey if you're
going to United States you should visit
my friend Paul ran I said cool
so I went to visit mr. Wran and the next
day was my faculty talk so what a good
day
to do like any job talk right I was like
so happy I like met my dream person so
when I came here I wasn't nervous
luckily I should have been nervous but
anyways that was a big moment and some
what I did when I arrived at MIT I asked
Nikolas if we could bring Paul rent and
I remember michaelis said Paul Rand is
Steve still alive is he still around I
said oh yeah he's around and we were
worried if people would come to see Paul
Rand talked and also Paul Paul made it
much more difficult by saying he wanted
to speak at 10 a.m. and Nikolas might
not remember this but Nikolas said no no
and no one's gonna come at 10 a.m. for
p.m. haven't come at 4 p.m. I said can
you come at 4 p.m.
professor Negroponte he says no I'm
coming at 10 a.m. if no one's gonna show
up at 4 p.m. I never wanted to talk to
them anyways so he showed up at 10 a.m.
and I'm sure Nikolas remembers the the
auditorium was packed it was standing
room only
it was an incredible outpouring for mr.
rent and design in general which was
exciting
arrogance I'd loved that moment where
she says arrogance and everyone kind of
like bristled would like yeah you know
but there's a Bob Sutton book about you
know [ __ ] you know but wait a second
I don't understand this well it's a fact
that artists might appear arrogant but
as when I when I ran Rhode Island School
of Design I was able to work with many
artists and I found this one thing I
didn't understand at the beginning well
I used to visit all the the lunch rooms
and bring my food around and sit with
students randomly to see if they'd let
me sit with them sometimes oh no no no
don't sit with us and like come over
here you know but one day there was a
young woman say come here come I says oh
no she wants to sit with me
so I sat with her and she's saying you
know I'm a I'm a freshman no no
it's coming something's coming freshmen
and it was really hard that first
semester you know I come from the
Midwest if it's all new to me I didn't
understand it didn't understand the
teachers it was just so hard every day I
just didn't know what to do and just
said now I'm in the second term and I
know where things are
I know what kind of questions to ask
it's all working really well but I have
to have confession to make I have to
confess that I don't feel alive and so I
remember like welcome back to my office
and the elevator opened and my friend
Jesse she was the Provost at the time
she was right there and said Jesse this
thing interesting thing happened to him
we're sitting this young woman and she
was saying this thing and just look they
may said well well of course she's an
artist our artist doesn't feel alive
unless they feel the struggle it's
through that struggle that they feel
alive so you may look like Ariane's but
it's not strength to be different that I
see is there and lastly persistence
right what a good one to end on think
about it I mean when you tell like
younger people today that there was a
time when there was this like dot-matrix
typeface not like you know an anti
aliased version of it but like five dots
by seven dots was all you got and I'm
now a product manager design lead at a
company where I'm trying to tell
everyone like do this no that's not the
way you have to do it do it this way
it's better no I think it's good this
way it gives me a sense of how easy it
is now comparative and Mariel was able
to convince people that maybe you need
this thing called Helvetica on one
screen maybe it has to be anti-alias so
it looks much more smooth to the eye
pleasurable so that kind of persistence
I can't imagine how hard it was for her
in the team back then to do what has
happened but look how amazing
information is today on our devices so
persistence good persistence
so all I can say now is I am at the very
end and I'm zero zero seconds and I want
to leave with this thought that Muriel
was one of the great teachers and all of
you are teachers in different ways too
so please consider your yourselves as
intellectual philanthropists people that
can give this away to other people they
give opportunities and I used to raise
money so I will do a thing for MIT press
if you have not bought this book or
aren't buying it yet by many for your
friends because it's a way to carry your
legacy forward thank you I'm gonna
introduce you guys so give me two
seconds because I also have to say one
other word which you may you guys may
not know but there's apparently a new
fund that's been created by the way mele
I believe it's Emily in Jeptha or is
anybody here from the Wade family know
what a raid it's a new fund at the MIT
press which will bear murals name and
its purpose as I understand it is to
help make the art and architecture and
design books easier to do and and sub
venture them and do whatever and yours
is the first so we not only want to hear
about the book but you should know it's
the first of the Muriel Cooper fund I
guess it's a little nepotistic for it to
be funding the Muriel book but at any
rate please come
like I guess they read your names and
they thank you thank you Nichols
my name is Rob Weisenberger this is
David Rainford we're co-authors of this
book which we hope you'll see soon
entitled Muriel Cooper and we just
wanted to make a few very basic
observations about the book about its
structure about the intent behind it
before that we wanted to thank the MIT
press for its enthusiasm about the
project for investing in it thank the
Media Lab for hosting and thank so many
people in this room from the family and
colleagues and friends of Cooper's the
archivist the librarians all these
people who helped to make this material
come alive for us so just a couple words
on on this this book the first
observation is pretty pretty
straightforward about its scale and
hopefully you'll appreciate it
it's a big book and we were really happy
to see that this book can stand up
beside Cooper's two great tomes the
Bauhaus of 1969 after which this book
takes some inspiration visually and
learning from Las Vegas of 1972 which is
mercifully back in print so we really
like that this book can hold its own
this book dedicated to Cooper beside
those two great tomes and that this book
is also about the person who helped take
us beyond the book so it feels
appropriate when you get into the book
you'll see that the epigraph to start
off with is a sort of confession of
Cooper's and she says I guess I'm never
sure that print is truly linear I guess
I'm never sure that print is truly
linear and she said this in the 90s when
she's already working in the digital
realm and it's - to us it seems like a
nice way to start a book because it's a
kind of it's a statement of ambivalence
it's a statement
very typically of cooper's the statement
of ambivalence a statement of
possibility as well she's just gotten
done explaining that the specificity of
the printed book versus the
possibilities of the digital and then
she drew back tracks and says actually I
guess I'm never sure that print is truly
linear and so it seemed like an
appropriately self reflexive way to
start a book but also appropriate to her
who felt even as she moved into the
digital world that the book was a
specific kind of technology the Codex
book had its own set of possibilities
and simultaneity for her versus
linearity she really strove for
simultaneity not that you start here and
end here but in all of her work whether
it was a highly layered image that comes
at you all at once or can be accessed in
different ways or a video disc that you
can skip around from based on your own
path or the hyperlinking of of the world
we now live in simultaneity
non-linearity was so important to Cooper
and I think she showed that books can do
that and so we kind of wanted to start
with this very equivocal and self
reflexive acknowledgment of the power
that ebooks still actually hold that she
she showed to us very very sort of basic
observation but in the table of contents
we separated out there's a text portion
and an image portion and that's the
structure of the Bauhaus book that
Cooper designed as well I mean she
inherited that from the it's German
predecessor but we both wrote essays on
her early in late work respectively her
work in print and software respectively
and their essays their attempts their
brief and then we show you the work and
we really wanted to foreground the work
and let people enter in either direction
and we think that you know at different
times maybe the text will be galvanizing
for people who are words at other times
the images will be at other time still
the images may feel dated and then
they'll feel new again so so we wanted
to provide these two ways of accessing
it and you'll see that there are these
two these two texts and then there's
these these three sections
we call them portfolios
sections and they respectively they
represent her work they are design and
teaching and research and they were
successive categories in her career she
did them one after another and of course
there they bleed into one another
they're not such crisp distinctions but
the point I wanted to make that that
struck me that struck us about Cooper
was that design and teaching and
research we didn't write those
categories that she did and that I think
we've heard tonight that her career
intersected with a lot of interesting
people it's actually Paul Rand who we
just heard about who recommended her for
a job at the MIT press it's you know
great design luminary Georgia campus
before that who brought her on to MIT
she designed the Bauhaus book when
Herbert Beier the great Bauhaus master
wasn't available she's at the MIT Media
Lab with a whole set of luminaries many
of whom are in this room and yet she
designed and redesigned her own career
in really interesting ways
so these chapters design and teaching
and research we quote her in the book as
saying you know I very deliberately
decided I no longer wanted to be a
designer in traditional sense and she
uses the word deliberately about three
times in a sentence or two and that idea
of the deliberate the purposive the
intentional that she was forging her way
creating careers in field that simply
didn't exist with a lot of assists from
the brilliant minds around her but that
she wrote these chapters so the the last
thing I want to say is you know it's
it's striking when you hear about when
when we hear about Muriel tonight I mean
we didn't know her personally and we're
very aware of that I mean I was I was 10
when she died
you will David will tell his his you
know passing connection but you know we
didn't know her and we respect you know
all of the help of those who did and we
want to provide this way in it's
striking that she's simultaneously by
everyone's account this kind of
firecracker this incredible personality
so idiosyncratic and yet is not well
known and didn't really have the time in
her own life because she was working so
hard
often behind the scenes to really
consolidate her work in a clearer way
and say this is my career and it
probably wasn't even in her character to
talk about herself or her work in that
way to her great credit so this book is
that attempt to to with a little
distance to consolidate her career and
look at it with some perspective so we
hope you enjoy it and with that I wanted
to turn it over to David Knight okay I
did not know Muriel Cooper either as Rob
made clear I did however in I think it
was January of 1995 I was a young
designer working in New York not knowing
what I was doing and I thought it would
be fantastic to come and study at the
Media Lab and I arranged to make a visit
up here in January of 1995 to visit the
the vlw
and at that point I saw some of the work
on screen actually Lisa Straus Feld was
a student here at the time and was I
remember thinking that was fantastic
that she had studied that she was an
architect before but when I saw this
work then the next time I ended up not
coming back to graduate school because I
went to go work at IDEO in San Francisco
in 1995 and I went to work for Geeta
Solomon who was a student from the Media
Lab and who had finished and what was
striking at the time out in San
Francisco I was hired as an interaction
designer which was a fairly quite a new
field at the time
Meera Cooper's work and specifically the
information landscapes were presented as
kind of primary material as I was
starting to understand what might happen
on a on a screen in this relationship to
design so that was that was soon not so
long after the TED talk in Monterey
which we've heard described couple times
tonight from people who were there and
who
organized it anyway when I first when I
first saw this saw the information
landscapes work it was but it was first
as printed images an article by Jan
Abrams and ID magazine I think and as
soon I saw it moving not very long after
that and I was struck as a designer with
the way in which familiar typographic
relationships which which conveyed
meaning which usually were done with
bold or sighs or two dimensional
approaches seemed to be completely
intact but just another dimension was
added to it and of course that's the
dimension of that's a third dimension
but it's also a dimension of time more
consequentially here and I recognize
this as work those happening on-screen
that opened up a whole set of
possibilities but I recognized it coming
from specifically a kind of design place
it was about ten years before I came
into contact with her work again and
during that time I was shocked that a
lot of the a lot of this work I didn't
hear discussed within graphic design or
interaction design extensively during
that time period may as my own remove
from whatever scenes were talking about
it but it was just absent and in 2005 I
came back to MIT and I was doing some
graphic design work with the Center for
Advanced visual studies which was at the
end of its kind of a run and I stumbled
into a closet up there which was filled
with posters they were just stacked one
on top of each other absolutely fabulous
fantastic things very excited to find
these things started to pull them out
and at the same time I found a resident
like a CV from Muriel Cooper at the
Center for Advanced visual studies from
I think step 1971 and III expected that
these posters were likely designed by
Muriel Cooper I was quickly corrected as
many of them weren't but what I
recognized in these was a similar
approach to what I had seen in the
information landscapes which seem to be
a kind of deep investment in the kind of
temporal aspect of making a piece of
graphic design work so whether it's the
rotations that
are in the print on the left which used
the kind of staging of a printing press
as a way to generate form or on the
right which is made with a split
fountain which is another way of kind of
using the tools to to produce the
graphic effect essentially now in the
book these are these are several spreads
from the book in the book we've made a
real attempt to show the things that we
found pieces of Muriel Cooper's work and
her students work and ancillary
materials as much as artifacts as
possible and so you see something like
the mechanical artwork for the MIT press
logo which is presented with the masking
tape on it in the sketch the original
sketch that looks like it led to this
proposal for a logo on the Left these
are largely left unframed by kind of
writing essentially and the idea as Rob
described as well was to make this kind
of source book for other people to
continue this work it seemed given our
distance from the material and the real
situation it also seemed like a the most
productive positive thing we could do
was present this work so that other
people can take up the project and so
that other people can get excited about
this singular collection of design of
design and and continue it forward
whether through research or taking the
ideas etc now you know it gets sewn up
in this giant in this rather large book
which is very beautifully produced by
the MIT press we were thrilled with the
way that it came out yeah but on the on
the spine of this book is down in the
bottom you know you don't have to see is
is a piece of Muriel Cooper's work that
we all know well but seeing in situ not
removed and so this this would have to
be one of my favorite pieces of graphic
design and the way in which it
oscillates between a kind of figurative
typographic thing and what looks like a
machine readable graphic but here we see
it doing the work it was meant to do
which is identify this book as MIT
and I just think we both of us feel
quite honored to have it published by
MIT given the subject matter that's in
it so we hope you'll look at it enjoy it
and make some work from it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody I'm Todd Mack over and
we have a wonderful panel here to talk
about mural as a teacher and I think
we'll have an opportunity to talk about
the culture of the visible language
workshop as well
we have Ron McNeil who was really murals
partner for the entire time that the
visible language workshop ran and really
ran it together so we're gonna hear from
ron about how it started and what it
meant and how it worked
Lisa Straus Feld who was was mentioned
started out as an architect but came
studied design with Muriel and visible
language workshop as one of the world's
most prominent designers worked with
pentagram independently and now is at
the new school University and David
small who when he started working with
Muriel he told me just before I hadn't
remembered this I hadn't done any design
work at all and found his way to Muriel
through photography and became a
designer in murals tutelage started a
small design firm which is one of the
most prominent design firms in the world
so we'll talk to them in just a second I
just wanted to make a couple of comments
first one is that I was one of the very
first people to be hired at the Media
Lab people like Muriel and Nicholas were
at MIT before the Media Lab
but when the building opened I was one
of the first people to come here and
Muriel was one of the very kindest
people to everybody but but I remember
certainly to me you know I came here I
was 30 years old I think I was a
musician an artist and Muriel understood
that it wasn't so easy to be an artist
in a culture even like even the Media
Lab but a culture like MIT so she never
said too much about it but she always
found time to check in just to see how I
was doing to see if things were okay and
to see if that part of my creative work
here was was being nurtured she really
cared and now one of the things that I'm
proud of stuff of all the things that I
do is that I'm the Muriel Cooper
professor here at MIT
and not a day goes by when I don't think
about somehow trying to live up to her
example as a designer and an artist and
as a mentor and as somebody who helps to
shape this place and as a human being
because she really was as close to the
soul of the Media Lab as as anybody and
I'll just tell you one little story
before I turn it over to our panelists
and Ron will recognize this but but you
two won't it has to do with her as a
teacher and as a mentor so um in the
early days of the Media Lab the place
was small enough that when we would go
through the admissions process to pick
our students we'd actually all sit
around a big table we do this a few
times iteratively and all the folders
for all the students would be on the
table and the place was small enough
that we'd all read the folders for
everybody and we pass them around the
table and the idea was we'd have three
or four of these meetings and each of
the meetings you were supposed to make a
shorter and shorter list you'd read the
folders and you're supposed to say okay
they're 50 people who want to be in my
group and now my job is to figure out
the 30 and now it's the 10 and that and
every time we'd make a list on the board
and Nicholas you know runs a pretty
tight ship and he would you know make
sure that every time we'd kind of winnow
down the list and we'd even write the
names on the board of our short list and
you know it's the important thing to do
one of the biggest things is to pick the
right students here and I'll never
forget you know all of us you know we
wanted to follow what Nicholas wanted us
to do so we would winnow down our lists
and sure you know we get to the second
third you know we get to the final list
and we'd have okay here but here are the
two people I really want to admit and we
get to Muriel we say okay Muriel what's
your short list say well I've got 20
people and they because I got 20 people
now and I need more time as 20 people
and so part of it was the Chinese menu
thing about maybe not being able to
decide but I really think it's because
she took so much time to think about
every single one of those applicants and
to figure out where there was something
special which might not be so obvious at
you know in the normal way of judging a
student and to figure out not only
she wanted to nurture but what kind of
group she could bring together to make
the visible language workshop special it
was really amazing they drove Nicholas
crazy but she was also the only one I
think it's because you were such close
friends but also you respected each
other so much he's the only one who he
would let get away with that but choice
but so here's here are the kind of
people she admitted so I'd like to maybe
start with Ron just to you cuz you were
here at the very beginning just tell us
how the visible language workshop
started why it started how it worked I
thought that it would be nice to see the
very very grubby beginning of her third
act where we started the the vlw so the
via dlw
story starts in the early 1970s way
before the internet way before the PC
with me a photographer turned print
maker in my workspace on the fourth
floor of building five of the department
of architecture slaving over a hot
offset press teaching a class in non
silver imaging image making called
photographic s-- so before I met her
Muriel and I shared a friend Tom Norton
who told her about my offset press and
as it turned out Muriel was looking to
start act three of her career outside of
MIT press so you might imagine that
Muriel was visualizing something like
this when Tom told her about my press
but of course you'd be wrong because
that's what she was imagining right the
scene of a group of eager very smart
future designer disruptors with Muriel
as the lioness den mother teaching them
in the ways of disruption
so after she came on board officially
what Muriel soon created was an iconic
humanities distribution class called
messages and means that was consistently
oversubscribed because it asked students
who normally spent all day thinking
abstractly to connect their imagination
in their hands in creative exploration
and of course many of them had never
ever even tried to do that before so
Muriel felt strongly that the author and
maker should be the same person or more
practically back then that the gap
between the author and the maker should
be collapsed as much as possible and in
search of the closest thing to an
interactive experience possible
Muriel throughout all of the then
conventions of reproduction technology
to get as close to a hands-on
interactive design production
experiences as was possible often going
from concept to mask to plate to printed
piece in one class so she called this
iconic class project a rotation where
the students would use square paper
create the mask by working directly on
acetate with press type but use only one
plate and rotate the paper between color
changes notice the female press operator
so sadly very few of these pieces have
actually survived and the ones that I'm
going to show you are not fabulous but
you know they're still I think worth
seeing here's a the split fountain very
very popular the third color here's
another approach and yet another
so she also inherited a basic visual
literacy Freshman Seminar called
creative saying she had three assistants
in a class of sixty bright-eyed
bushy-tailed students and here they're
taking part in a sky art event so here
they're mapping their physical social
and family relationships and then below
exploring instant reproduction
technologies and of course they explored
the book form just a few examples of
probably an incredibly varied class so
our computational explorations started
in earnest when I got a grant to build a
billboard painting machine as you see
here it worked well for about an
afternoon but the part of the project
that really excited both muriel me was
the interactive color computer graphic
image and text editing system that was
needed in order to create the images for
the billboard painter so after a
three-year collaboration between many
grad and undergrad assistants we had one
of the first artist workstations capable
of synthesizing image and type in
near-real-time
sadly the crude image type handling
capability was a constant frustration
for muriel but it was also extremely
hard to fix because the cpu that we were
using was about as fast as the first
Macintosh so there was a time just be
sort of the middle of the project just
about every morning I would come in and
see a new function or a new image added
by one of the student artists that were
informed by work by other students that
had been done previous days the 300
megabyte image math death
space was a big canvas they let
everybody else share ideas in a free and
easy way and of course Miura was not
off-limits as a subject so when we first
moved into the Media Lab the tools were
still just as frustrating for muriel as
ever but things began to change for the
good for the good when david small
seguro
ishizaki mrs. strauss Feld and earl
Renison began the information landscape
work over two days okay David you might
take it from there good introduction
okay so so as I think has been mentioned
multiple times I was involved in that
famous a couple of days in Monterey at
the Ted 5 conference and I was that
waiter that Nicholas described that I
thought we were gonna go to Monterey we
were gonna speak on the second day and
then I was gonna see Big Sur and it was
gonna be like a fantastic thing instead
Muriel angled from like the moment we
landed to get us almost like the very
last spot scheduled and we spent those
three days me hunched over the computer
and her changing her mind over that so
if we can switch to the two my phone
here one thing that's always bothered me
about that piece was that we really
didn't have at the time any way of
documenting it except to make a kind of
videotape which was always so like fuzzy
and and wasn't alive and two years ago
when the Museum of Modern Art this piece
for their collection I said what do you
mean acquire the piece or you you want
what what is it and they said well I
guess the videotape I said well okay but
maybe we can do more and I there's a
group here at the Media Lab there's a
lot of different research groups but
there's another group called next
which manages the network and all the
computers and I wrote to them I said do
you have our backups from 23 years ago
and they were like oh no we they're
online I'll just email you later so all
of the original source code was there
it's still there and I inveigled my
husband to pour it everything to the
phone over the past couple of weeks so
this is the this is effect simile of the
presentation that was given at Ted from
the original source code and this is
unlike the videotape this is really what
it what it felt like and so imagine you
know this week and I can see from this
angle and I could see from this angle
but then you have mural over your
shoulder saying like she'd be learning
and common sense up until like an hour
or two before we went onstage was like
one of the most terrifying life and then
she talked I had no idea going into it
what she was going to say she never made
a note or jaw did anything down she was
gonna say she just talked and I like
latched on to everything she said as as
much as I could and try to keep up with
her so so anyway just I just wanted to -
I didn't want it people did not have
sort of a feel for what this actually
was so the end of the little story
hopefully not the end end of the story
but the end for today was that we
submitted it to the Apple App Store last
night because I was hoping I'd tell
everyone you could just like go to the
App Store and download it and they they
kicked it out they said it had
insufficient functionality minimal sorry
minimal functionality and but yes it was
just about going down and down tighter
and tighter and then and then this idea
- of you could look at something one way
but then maybe you could look at a
different way you can go back to this
way and it this way and and to me like I
just sat there for four weeks flipping
back and forth
now I can read this but the other thing
is still on the screen but now I can
read that but now I can do this and it
was just like one of the most exciting
times of my life to have been involved
in this and I'm just happy to be able to
share with oh thanks I'm gonna start
with a little detail so when we got
those silicon graphics workstations at
the Media Lab which happened just after
I arrived they came with built-in fonts
and they they were awful but they also
in 3d I think all of them had thickness
like you were almost sort of required to
use a Z dimension and the I think that
you know implying that the software
developers from SGI were focused on you
know a big extruded text and one of the
I think it's an important detail because
the way those fonts were built by Dave
and the team was really not something
that was really designed into the
software that you know landed on those
workstations and it was very much that
condition that they they had absolutely
no thickness and the ability for them to
disappear on rotation that was really so
much about what that time was about but
backing up
I just want to I'm so grateful that this
event is happening especially grateful
that this book exists thank you to rob
David and MIT press for making it happen
and to the designers the book is so
beautiful and it will it's it's such a
perfect tribute to mural Cooper's work I
was really honored to be asked to do the
forward and I was given not spelled
Edline to write the foreword for the
book I thought there's no way I will
meet this deadline
and and it did much to my surprise and
the the words the the anecdotes the
experience really just kind of came out
of me and it was such a pleasure and
really meaningful right now I'm assuming
no one's read the foreword yet but the
it in many ways it reads as a kind of
instruction manual for how to run a
really successful research lab and sort
of serving my own current agenda mural
part of murals brilliance I think was in
her collaborators and I also I mean you
know the vlw would not have been the
place it was of course without Ron and
Dave
saguru I know Louie Weitzman's here I
mean that the whole the group of people
that she carefully curated was really
extraordinary so I encourage you to
actually read the whole book the essays
are incredible
Nicholas's afterwards is incredible and
again if you want a sense of what it was
like to be in the vlw please please read
it just a couple little anecdotes to
share and this is something that um so
maybe we'll have a conversation about
this at some point but um mural for bid
come technology conversations at the vlw
literally this is something that I read
about in the foreword you could not talk
about technology in front of her she
would tell you to go to another room
it's true right yeah and there was
something incredibly important about
this and absolutely key to what she was
able to do in separating these
conversations that were really about
experience about design about
communication about messages from how it
was done she never let technology lead I
mean we had those conversations of
course but they did not lead and I I
write about this before I I feel like I
did bring this ethic what I learned to
pentagram which of course now when I
joined pentagram I was the kind of the
first digitally flew
partner to join my team was very much I
mean I built my practice doing the you
know digital interactive work of my
partner's who were doing these you know
still doing these amazing identity
programs for corporate institutional
clients but what really became strategic
of course as we knew was to have that
type of work be done by all the partners
for their identity programs and again
you should be the forward but um when
when years ago when people came to
pentagram when I started they asked for
a certain artifact of design a poster an
annual report a book and that has
completely changed and again it's
something that be so what what clients
now ask for is we've educated the
clients to ask for their message to be
communicated to an audience and it's the
work has become really media agnostic
anyway all of these things I really took
away from my experience in the vlw I I
talked about there there was a you know
group of students with diverse set of
backgrounds from the computational side
architecture design the work mural had
really guided us she didn't she taught
in a very unusual way I didn't even know
that I was being taught exactly but I
was really being guided and in hindsight
I look back and and some ways the
heaviest hand was really in the choice
of typefaces and there was there are
many weights but there was one type face
which was Helvetica so this diversity of
work that we produced had came together
in that way and lastly I had to write
about what I wanted to write and sort of
conclude the forward with what I felt
really motivated her I think she was
there were contradictions in that I
distinct
remember this conversation with either
Ron or another designer graphic designer
who is visiting and they were trying I
was just over here in this conversation
with mural and they were talking about
the one word that would be kind of
devastating to hear about their work do
you remember this oh yeah
and do you remember the word oh yeah
nice oh okay I had the different
different memory matter what the word
was as long as you cried the word I
remember it was decorative yes similar
similar so so on the one hand you're you
know wanted there to be meaning there
she wanted to communicate she wanted it
to map to the experience of the content
she wanted to represent the content she
wanted to work to represent the content
on the other hand another memory I have
is I was on the reality engine flying
her through a financial visualization I
had done she actually gave me the
Morningstar floppy disks so I could use
that information and I remember you know
I was kind of driving the the demo and
she was sitting back in the chair and
she really she asked me to kind of pause
she really wanted to occupy the space of
numbers she actually despite the other
comment this contradiction is that she
wanted to feel it she wanted to be
seduced by the form and I think it was
really those two things of wanting the
meaning you know wanting the content and
wanting just the the seduction and the
pleasure of you know beautiful form and
flying as Richard said she wanted to fly
so lastly when I tried to sum this up in
the foreword I was writing a sentence
about what really motivated her there's
an em-dash I was trying to put the words
together and I concluded that what
motivated her really was what was
possible so well thank you and great to
be here
I think with the we're running a little
late so we'll just take another couple
of minutes David I was gonna ask you you
you said outside
you said boy I'm looking back and gee I
didn't really study with Muriel for all
that long it was only ten years and my
recollection looked longer
yeah but my recollection is you changed
quite a lot over those ten years I just
thought maybe you'd say a little bit
about what you were like when you
started with me Roland yeah that she I
mean like many people she changed my
life but I I feel like she really
changed the trajectory of my life I when
I started I I hadn't written any
software per se at least not at MIT
because as an undergraduate I had worked
in the darkroom but that was all just
with chemistry and I didn't really know
anything about design and I had finished
my undergrad I didn't have a job I
didn't quite know what I was going to do
and I don't recall if we was she or I
but we talked about like one what should
I do next that she's will come you know
do do work in the visible language
workshop and you know thank God that I
did so I started out like that
Bob savathun taught me all he knew about
software and I taught other people and
we all taught each other none of us a
lot of people came to the vlw not
knowing how to program and none of us
started by taking a computer science
course and out of program we taught each
other and that was going to be enough
and yeah those 10 years like everything
changed so dramatically in the way that
I had absorbed all this idea about stuff
and I never felt like she taught me and
like I was being taught I kind of
complained about it sometimes where's
the textbook is there ever gonna be a
textbook or even working on the textbook
no there was no there was no chance
there was everything meet the textbook
yeah it come out it which you know a lot
of people at the lab they had a group
and they slowly developed that book I
was not gonna happen but it was like
this you know
like this this is the Bob staffs can
view of workshop and it was like tied
together with duct tape and there's a
bunch of speakers and smoke kind of
things and and at the end of it I had
learned all of this stuff and I didn't
even quite realize how much she was
teaching yeah I have two more really
quick questions one's for you Ron
it's it's I was thinking at the end of
the day these last two days have been
our members sponsored days at the Media
Lab at the end of the day yesterday
after FBO was hectic all day our newest
faculty member Danielle wood it was a
remarkable young woman whose works at
NASA and also works on community
activism was walking around looking at
demos and she came to our group and my
students were all around and and she
asked you know she's just starting at
the Media Lab and she said what is it
that makes a group bond what is it that
makes a group feel special and I
immediately thought that of all the
groups I've ever seen at the Media Lab
there was something about the feeling at
the visible language workshop that was
just special and I was wondering you
know just a few words can you think what
how that worked why that happened tell
Danielle because well as you saw we
chose superb people and there really was
no roadmap there were there was a work
space and some some you know general
ideas of things that and we all sort of
dived in and got to work I mean I don't
think it was much more complicated than
that
my last quick question for Lisa is you
told me before that you have a daughter
which is 13 years then it'll be 10 I
should be 10 to be 10 who who's
interested in design interested in MIT
and just thought maybe you tell everyone
what her name is her name is Muriel
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Uriel's nephew Jonathan and on
behalf of Uriel's family many of whom
are here tonight
a big thank you to the press and to the
Media Lab for hosting and including us
in this great event much of the talk
today has been about murals role as a
teacher or designer but before she was
either she was the first born child of
immigrant Russian and polish parents
living in Brookline it was a typical
middle-class family Jack her father was
a master electrician and her mother
Jenny stayed at home to take care of the
family muriel or kandi as she was called
their nickname was followed by the birth
of my mother Helene who was also known
as honey
and lastly Charlotte who is here tonight
who was known as chickie wonderful names
Muriel had a pretty normal childhood the
only hint of what was to become a
brilliant career might have been a
passion for doodling and her being what
at the time was called a tomboy but
today would simply be described as being
fearless strong-willed and independent
when it was time for college Miro
attended Ohio State but the goal of
getting her BFA but when Jack and Jenny
her parents visited her on parents day
weekend they were shocked to discover
that the dorm that Muriel was staying in
was filled with girls of questionable
character who were smoking leading
clothes all over the floor and God knows
what else and their opinion Ohio State
was far too racy a place for their
little girl
and so Muriel was allowed to finish the
year and then was brought back to Boston
where she enrolled at the Massachusetts
College of Art to pursue a career in art
education when I applied to art schools
and was obsessing about which art school
I should attend
Muriel calmly told me to relax the
school isn't important she said it's who
you go to school with and I can see why
she felt that way murals classmates at
mass art included a who's who of future
designers and artists including Tom Wong
and Jackie Casey both of whom could
often be
found sitting around the Cooper dining
room table pulling a Charette for the
next morning's class the three became
lifelong friends Jack and Jenny often
worried about Muriel why wasn't she
married why didn't she conform like her
siblings why did she dress the way she
dressed they could only see that Muriel
didn't fit the mold that her younger
sisters did and they didn't see her
brilliance Muriel was my aunt but she
was much more than that to me she was my
mentor my idol and my best friend she
was cool she was loud she could be brash
and she was a big part of why I became a
designer well to be honest in large part
it was because of her basement every
year would start with a call Muriel
asked me if I'd like to come by some
weekend and help clean up her basement
and every year I left at the chance I
would spend hours upon hours in that
basement with Muriel asking her
questions about where she got Miss or
that object where she thought a
particular item should go and she would
patiently show me how to plan categorize
and organize looking back I guess it was
the equivalent to mr. Miyagi's wax on
wax off method of karate training except
for a young designer to me that basement
was a playground a library a time
capsule and a toy store all rolled into
one and I could remember the contents of
each box and shelf like it was yesterday
walking down the steep basement stairs I
spy a rusty erector set barely contained
by its decaying box it was a gift from
Uriel's parents to keep her occupied
while she was covering from appendicitis
when she was 10 years old and Charlotte
recently told me when Muriel first asked
for an erector set her mother replied
what on earth would a girl do with an
erector set and great things apparently
a large wok framed by bamboo steaming
basket sits in a shelf part of a
collection of kitchen gadgets a
byproduct of murals adventures in
Chinese cooking my brother David lived
at murals house while he attended bu in
the 60s and we mean remembers going with
Muriel to Chinatown where she would
spend half of her time purchasing exotic
ingredients with barely pronounceable
names and the other half chatting with
the store owners Muriel loved exploring
world cuisines long before it became
commonplace and one section of the basin
is filled with clothes
a few from India with fantastic colors
and patterns some from Japan rich in
their simplicity in detail and many many
many from Filene's basement I think it
was Elise brink a good friend of murals
who told the story of how she joined in
on when a murals famous trips to buy
liens meal went up to the returns desk
and placed a very large pile of clothes
in the counter and the woman at the
counter slowly looked through the pile
and shook her head and explained they
couldn't accept the return the clothes
had been purchased over a year ago it
was too late to return them and without
missing a beat
Uriel calmly explained that the reason
she hadn't returned them sooner was
because she'd been locked away in a
mental institution for the past year and
that she had just been released they
nervously accepted her return their
watches some analog and some digital
most are broken which might have been a
factor in their seeming inability to
arrive anywhere on time large piles of
parking tickets held together by rubber
bands or a souvenir of her apparent
refusal to ever pay for parking
causing the Cambridge police to show up
at her office at MIT and threatened to
cuff and arrest her on the spot in order
to get her to pay them and there are
family photographs magazines and
clippings one clipping features a
photograph of Muriel standing in an
all-white room and the headline states
designer boldly paints home interior
white and the article goes on to
describe how Muriel Cooper of Brookline
in a radical move breaking with
tradition has decided to paint the
interior of her house completely white I
know crazy on the floor sits an unopened
pack of cigarettes and as I bent down to
pick them up I get a clear image of
murals habit of approaching a random
smoker a total stranger asking if she
might smell their cigarette she would
hold it in their hands delicately like a
wine connoisseur might hold the cork of
the fine vintage wine deeply inhaling
from the glowing tip a look of ecstasy
spreading over her face I've quit
smoking she'd explained
but God I missed the smell there's a box
of calculators in the floor a souvenir
of a calculus class one of many that
Muriel audited at MIT I remember how
frustrated she would get doing problem
sets often cursing and swearing out loud
and how at the time I wondered why
anyone would take a math class unless
they absolutely had to there are cameras
lots and lots of cameras 35-millimeter
4x4 and larger slide projectors movie
cameras 16 millimeter 8 millimeter super
8 and of course Polaroid cameras a
medium that she loved right next to them
is what can only be described as a
shrine to all things sony recorders
microphones headphones Walkman Betamax
cameras and players laser discs editing
equipment I really realized that I'm
looking at the complete history of Sony
Corporation up to 1994 is curated by
Muriel Cooper there are toys in a shelf
mostly robots from Japan her latest
fascination and they trigger a memory of
the elaborate Viking ship muriel gave me
when i was five or so complete with
articulated oars that would row and sink
as they sit slowly moved sails billowing
across the floor it was and continues to
be the best present I ever got
but most of the basement is taken up by
books and I take frequent breaks having
picked up a book to place it on a shelf
only to stop sit in the floor and leaf
through its pages
Bauhaus learning from Las Vegas file
under architecture the Whole Earth
Catalog books by Paul ran Josef Albers
pushpin magazine uppercase lowercase
comic books not even reading just
absorbing the pacing the structure the
color the visual impact that each page
contained and I was mesmerized by the
cover designs the fonts and the images
and at the time I didn't even realize
her connection to these books that I was
falling in love with every item in that
basement was precious to Muriel if I
asked why I couldn't throw out a
calculator the Betamax player or a gear
bag all them long since broken or
obsolete Muriel would comment on how the
interface packaging your design was cute
and cute was the highest form of
flattery they
Muriel could be stowing an object or
idea we spent many weekends together at
the flea market in Swanton coming upon a
vendor selling an interesting old sign
or a piece of equipment or poster Nero
would immediately start a conversation
with the seller she was not only curious
about the story behind an object but the
story of the owner as well and after 10
minutes or so of chatting she would stop
pause look out over reading glasses in
remark cute and the poor vendor would
look so confused was cute meant as a
put-down should they be offended or
complimented they didn't understand the
coming from Uriel
cute was the highest of compliments I
was with Muriel when she died in Mass
General Hospital in May of 1994 and I
can honestly say like many of you not a
day has gone by that I haven't thought
about her I'm not a religious man but
I've always liked the song Rock and Roll
Heaven which goes if there's a Rock and
Roll Heaven well you know they've got a
hell of a band so who knows maybe
there's a graphic design heaven and
Jackie Tom and Muriel are in a white
cloud filled room sitting around the
table laughing and drinking wine they're
solving design problems we can't
possibly imagine it's just another day
of a perfect never-ending Charette then
suddenly at this very moment
Muriel pauses gets that twinkle in her
eye appears out over her reading glasses
and comments on how cute our celebration
here today has been thank you
[Applause]
two more short speakers and I'd like to
thank you for coming you will not see me
again
and Joey Ito is our next speaker and Amy
brand who's the head of the MIT press is
our last speaker if a parent can give
their child to a foster home or to
somebody else and be really happy with
where that child is placed I in some
sense gave my child to Joey
eita who's been the director of the
Media Lab for he reminded me yesterday
it's almost six years I think of it as
yesterday and when Joey joined it was
the best thing that happened to this
place so Joey you didn't know Muriel but
you're cut from the same cloth
thank you everybody and I really
appreciate everybody coming together to
celebrate mural and it's interesting
it's it's not the happiest thing but
we've recently lost Seymour and Marvin
and this feels to me like a kind of
culmination of this sort of historical
retrospective of the founding faculty of
the Media Lab and and I think it's a for
me in addition to hearing about all
their work through students and
faculties Nikolas meeting all the people
who were connected to them is and
listening to the conversations really
helps me understand where a lot of this
stuff comes from and this kind of very
strong creativity disobedience and this
sort of fearlessness that sort of
embodies the Media Lab now I i-i've
known Nikolas for a long time but as I
start to see these other people who were
involved I I'm starting to understand
more and more about the DNA and and it's
I think quite a testament to the
founding faculty at the Media Lab that
31 years now later you can still feel
the DNA and I think that you know this
the fact that we're still you know on a
trajectory that was set by the original
founders and set so strongly is is a
testament to both their vision and their
character and so you know today's been
really wonderful and sort of
understanding that I'm peculiarly sort
of overlapping with Maryland that I'm
also on the board of the MIT press on
author there and also the director the
Media Lab and so and I think Meryl
played a really important role in
bringing the press and the media lab
together and we're also continuing that
and we I think there's a demonstration
in the in the auditorium but we've
launched a journal called the Journal of
design and science so a lot of art mary
has this sort of wonderful krebs cycle
that I think I got from John my ADA who
got it from rich gold but but this this
sort of four quadrants where you have
art and science and design and
engineering and we've done a lot of art
and engineering at the Media Lab but
this sort of design and science axis
head head head
been fully explored in my view and so we
created a journal and the idea was
really that we brought a lot of hard
sciences into the Media Lab and what you
realize when you meet hard scientists is
that they tend to be very focused and
not very aware of the context about the
sensibilities that you need when you
think about things and not really
responsible necessarily for the sort of
overall sensibility of the stuff that
they're interacting with and conversely
a lot of the designers we've talked to
or I've talked to especially when you
look at MIT we have hundreds of classes
that have the word design but the sort
of design alum Marilla has sort of
morphed into systems design and design
of business practices and design of all
kinds of things it's become very
engineering and there are even sort of
moves to sort of remove the aesthetic
side of design and one of the things
that I've noticed as we look at complex
self adaptive systems like the climate
like the human body that what's missing
is the kind of sensibility it's it's
you're doing things without this
approach of trying to make the thing
work in a wonderful way and that in fact
the future of design is probably going
back to a sensibility and aesthetics a
kind of vision that I think we goes back
to where we were starting and so so to
me designing bringing design and science
together bringing a new science into
design bringing design into science is
really important I think that that's
very much Media Lab very much MIT press
very much Merlin so so that's the
journal that we launched and we're
launching and also on a platform called
pub pub which was developed at the Media
Lab and it's a weird platform that
allows people to make comments allows
you to version track the versions and
it's it's very much a sort of living
document of a great sort of a new way of
thinking about peer review so it's much
more participatory so we'd love you to
take a look and tell us what you think
and I think let's see what else I'm
supposed to talk about yeah and I think
that the main thing is that you know as
we as we sort of embark on this next
journey thinking about how the work that
Morrell has done in the work that Amy
brand júlio meets the new director of
the MIT press how we can move this
forward is
one of the core missions of the Media
Lab so I really appreciate your past
support and your future support and with
that oh you know one last thing is I'm
supposed to say is that there's gonna be
in that room in the Alex Dreyfus
auditorium there will be a video of
Muriel's Ted five talk from 1994 so
please take a look at that during the
reception so with that I'd like to ask
Amy brand the director if it might be
best to come up thank you I just think
this has been a wonderful occasion and
thank you Joey
to mark this enduring partnership
between the press and the Media Lab the
way that Joey was was talking about the
Media Lab and you know this this sort of
quadrant or nexus of design and science
and art and technology is very much the
DNA of the MIT press as well and I think
a lot of that does go back to Muriel
so just 30 seconds for me lots of
thank-yous I wish to thank all of our
amazing speakers and panelists and in
particular I really want to thank
Nikolas for co-hosting this event I know
that it's a really really heartfelt for
you Nikolas and I appreciate that given
your deep friendship and I only wish
that I had known mural to one person
that we haven't mentioned this evening
but really needs to be thanked it is
Roger Conover who's sitting right over
there
Roger is celebrating 40 years as the art
and architecture editor at the MIT press
and has created this incredible legacy
around publishing in art and
architecture and design
you now you might have thought listening
to John my ADA that you're actually
gonna have to buy the book but in fact
due to a generous gift from the School
of Architecture and planning and Hashim
Sarkis everybody who was invited to this
event will leave with a copy of the book
so I would like to thank yes all that's
up there so thank you toshing but please
if you have a you know more people you
want to buy books for they're there for
purchase as well and pentagram we're
just in awe of you and in particular
again I'd like to thank Erin Fey and
Daisy Lee you produced those really
gorgeous animations we're definitely
going to try to make use of them at the
MIT press especially they call a fund
one at the end many people at the press
in the lab were involved in making this
event possible I can't try to list all
of them but there really are three
heroes of the evening they are Ellen
Hoffman and Kate shanigan and Kate
Straus a really incredible entire list
event planning trio they have impeccable
taste
they have good humor and they made being
involved in planning this event a real
joy and privilege for me so thank you
all again and thanks to all of you for
coming and please go and enjoy the
reception thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]